coffee on a Tuesday wait a second what
are you doing uh I thought I could just
do so maybe you've had this experience
before you were dreaming something
terrible like you were a little child
and your mother was yelling at you or a
giant evil baby was chasing you or you
saw the death of your wife whatever it
is you wake up feeling like [ __ ] you say
to yourself this is going to be a shitty
day I just have a feeling then getting
out of the shower you slip and fall and
layer you trip on the sidewalk and spill
your coffee everywhere and then you do
it again your friend calls you and says
she can't make it for lunch your job
application comes back rejected you burn
your hand on the stove there's no toilet
paper Desperate Housewives as a repeat
and you go to bed thinking what a shitty
day I knew it was going to be [ __ ] now I
think we can see right here that there
is nothing in the physical universe
which is guaranteeing a bad day for our
friend just know the universe doesn't
care what kind of day it is it's just
another rotation of 360 degrees but it's
here that Justin decides and all his
infinite wisdom that he's going to make
a prediction about the day the day is
going to be bad and all that bad stuff
really does happen so going to bed
justin believes that his prediction was
dead oh this is called a self-fulfilling
prophecy a false definition of the
situation evoking new behavior which
makes the originally false definition
come true logically or unconsciously
Justin created his own bad debt but he's
no different than any of us
self-fulfilling prophecies are
inexorably weaved into all of our lives
and we go through a life thinking that
this is going to be a bad day or I'm
definitely gonna get this job where that
students going to do really well or
these banks are in trouble so I oughta
withdraw my money just to be safe in
every example false definitions lead to
real outcomes like a bad day or a good
job or a straight-a student or a global
recession and the concept is old see
Oedipus Macbeth Tsar war but the idea of
self-fulfilling prophecy has much deeper
connotations than Justin's bad day each
and every one of our identities comes
into existence by way of them as cute
little infants we are psychologically no
different from animals we react to the
stimuli around us based on genetic
program we have no sense of meaning no
sense of ourselves no I den but as
babies our parents don't treat us like
animals no they
treat us like we do have identities they
talk to us like we can understand what
they're saying and what they're saying
is basically this we love you and you
are they show us what it is to be
recognized now in order for that
recognition to blossom into a self the
baby has to be courageous he has to risk
that first communication mama or dad
died and it is a risk the self is a very
tumultuous thing to have it's much
easier just to stay silent but those
good parents have been very encouraging
we'll love you no matter what they say
we'll applaud you or mirror you you can
trust in this way parents create their
children's identities by way of
self-fulfilling prophecy they predict
the identity and then organize their
behavior so as to bring it about
and the more loving the parent the more
courageous the baby will be now the self
is not a prize it needs to be worked on
all the time and this too is a constant
process of self-fulfilling prophecy
social reality is very flexible it's
subject to a variety of interpretations
we define the world and our place in it
every single day and as it was our
parents who literally created our
identities our conception of how they
see us remains a huge part of ourselves
like it or not and it's the same with
friends and loved it we are all
continuously creating one another's
identities and it's all self-fulfilling
prophecy now Justin had a bad day
there's no question about that and it
was self-fulfilling prophecy but one
thing you didn't see was when I called
him after the Desperate Housewives
disappointment and told him about my own
shitty day and listened to his getting
off the phone I said don't worry about
it but he [ __ ] happens and you could
always vent to me because I'm sure as
hell can I vent to you he laughed and
got off the phone went to his bed and
thought what a shitty day I knew it was
going to be shitty but well you never
know about tomorrow pretty good
what are you doing my son
sunset with my son did it I did